I wanted to be a psychologist since I
was a teenager and I spent years
pursuing that one goal I opened my
private practice as soon as I was
licensed it was a risky move not getting
a day job at a hospital or a clinic but
within one year my practice was doing
quite well and I was making more money
than I ever made before of course I was
a full-time student my entire life I
could have worked at McDonald's and made
more money than I ever made before that
one year mark came on a Friday night in
July I walked home to my apartment and
got into the elevator with a neighbor
who was a doctor in the ER the elevator
rose then it shuddered and stalled
between floors and the man who dealt
with emergencies for a living began
poking at the buttons and banging on the
door saying this is my nightmare this is
my nightmare and I was like and this is
my nightmare I felt terrible afterwards
though because I wasn't panicked and I
knew what to say to calm him down it was
just too depleted to do it I had nothing
left to give and that confused me after
all I was finally living my dream so why
wasn't I happy why did I feel so burnt
out for a few terrible weeks I
questioned whether I'd made a mistake
what if I had chosen the wrong
profession what if I had spent my entire
life pursuing the wrong career but then
I realized no I still loved psychology
the problem wasn't the work I did in my
office
it was the hours I spent ruminating
about work when I was home I closed the
door to my office every night but the
door in my head remained wide open and
the stress just flooded in that's the
interesting thing
about work stress we don't really
experience much of it at work we're too
busy we experience it outside of work
when we're commuting when we're home
when we're trying to rejuvenate it is
important to recover in our spare time
to de-stress and do things we enjoy and
the biggest obstruction we face in that
regard is ruminating because each time
we do it were actually activating our
stress response now to ruminate means to
true over the word refers to how cows
digest their food for those of you
unfamiliar with the joys of cow
digestion cows chew then they swallow
then they regurgitate it back up and
chew it again it's disgusting but it
works for cows it does not work for
humans because what we chew over are the
upsetting things the distressing things
and we do it in ways that are entirely
unproductive it's the hours we spend
obsessing about tasks we didn't complete
or stewing about tensions with a
colleague or anxiously worrying about
the future or second-guessing decisions
we've made now there's a lot of research
on how we think about work when we're
not at work and the findings are quite
alarming ruminating about work were
playing the same thoughts and worries
over and over again significantly
disrupts our ability to recover and
recharge in the off hours the more we
ruminate about work when we're home the
more likely we are to experience sleep
disturbances to eat unhealthy foods and
to have worse moods it may even increase
our risk of cardiovascular disease and
of impairing our executive functioning
the very skill sets we need to do our
jobs well not to mention the toll it
takes on our relationships and family
lives because people around us can tell
we're checked out and preoccupied now
those same studies found that while
ruminating about work when we're home
damages our emotional well-being
thinking about work in creative or
problem-solving ways does not because
those kinds of thinking do not elicit
emotional distress and more importantly
they're in our control we can decide
whether to respond to an email or leave
it till morning or whether we want to
brainstorm about work projects that
excite us but ruminations are
involuntary they're intrusive they pop
into our head when we don't want them to
they upset us when we don't want to be
upset they switch us on when we are
trying to switch off and they are very
difficult to resist because thinking of
all our unfinished tasks feels urgent
anxiously worrying about the future
feels compelling ruminating always feels
like we're doing something important
when in fact we're doing something
harmful and we all do it far more than
we realize back when I was burnt out I
decided to keep a journal for a week and
document exactly how much time I spent
ruminating and I was horrified by the
results it was over 30 minutes a night
when I was trying to fall asleep my
entire commute to and from my office
that was 45 minutes a day totally
checked out for 20 minutes during a
dinner party at the colleagues house
never got invited there again and 90
minutes during a friend's talent show
that coincidentally was 90 minutes long
in total that week it was almost 14
hours that's how much downtime I was
losing to something that actually
increased my stress try keeping a
journal for one week see how much you do
it that's what made me realize that I
still loved my work but ruminating was
destroying that love and it was
destroying my personal life too so I
read every study I could find and I went
to war against my ruminations now have a
change is hard it took real diligence to
catch myself ruminating each time and
real consistency to make the new habit
stay
but eventually they did I won my war
against women eating and I'm here to
tell you how you can win yours first you
need clear guardrails you have to define
when you switch off every night when you
stop working and you have to be strict
about it the rule I made to myself at
the time was that I was done at 8:00
p.m. and I forced myself to stick to it
now people say to me really you didn't
return a single email after 8:00 p.m.
you didn't even look at your phone no
not once because it was the 90s we
didn't have smart phones I got my first
not phone in 2007 you know the iPhone
had just come out and I wanted a phone
that was cool and hip
I got a blackberry I was excited though
you know my first thought was I get my
emails wherever I am and 24 hours later
I was like I get my emails wherever I am
I mean battling rumination was hard
enough when they just invaded our
thoughts but now they have this Trojan
horse our phones to hide within and each
time we just look at our phone after
hours we can be reminded of work and
ruminative thoughts can slip out and
slaughter our evening or weekend so when
you switch off switch off your email
notifications and if you have to check
them decide on when to do it so it
doesn't interfere with your plans and do
it only then cell phones aren't the only
way technology is empowering rumination
because we have an even bigger fight
coming telecommuting has increased 115
percent over the past decade and it's
expected to increase even more
dramatically going forward more and more
of us are losing our physical boundary
between work and home and that means
that reminders of work will be able to
trigger ruminations from anywhere in our
home when we lack a physical boundary
between work and home we have to create
a psychological one we have to trick our
mind into defining work and non-work
times and spaces
so here's how you do that first create a
defined work zone in your home even if
it's tiny and try to work only there try
not to work on the living-room couch or
on the bed because really those areas
should be associated with living and
bedding next when you're working from
home wear clothes you only wear when
you're working and then at the end of
the day change clothes and use music and
lighting to shift the atmosphere from
work to home make it a ritual now some
of you might think that's silly that
changing clothes and lighting will
convince my mind I'm no longer at work
trust me your mind will fall for it but
we're really smart our mind is really
stupid it falls to random associations
all the time right I mean that's why
Pavlov's dog began drooling at the sound
of a bell and my Ted speakers begin
sweating at the sight of a red circle
now those things will help but
lumination z' will still invade and when
they do you have to convert them into
productive forms of thinking like
problem-solving my patience Ally is a
good example Sally was given the
promotion of a lifetime but it came with
a price she was no longer able to pick
up her daughter from school every day
and that broke her heart so she came up
with a plan every Tuesday and Thursday
sati left work early picked up her
daughter from school played with her fed
her bathed her and put her to bed and
then she went back to the office and
worked past midnight to catch up only
said his rumination journal indicated
she spent almost every minute of her
quality time with her daughter
ruminating about how much work she had
to do ruminations often deny us our most
precious moments
Sally's rumination I have so much work
to do is a very common one and like all
of them it's useless and it's harmful
because we'd never think it when we're
at work getting stuff done we think it
when we're outside of work when we're
trying to relax or do things we find
meaningful like playing with our
children or having a date night with our
partner too
convert a ruminative thought into a
productive one you have to pose it as a
problem to be solved the problem-solving
version of I have so much work to do is
a schedule in question like where in my
schedule can I fit the tasks that are
troubling me or what can I move in my
schedule to make room for this more
urgent thing Oh even when do I have 15
minutes to go over my schedule all those
are problems that can be solved I have
so much work to do is not battling
rumination is hard but if you stick to
your guardrails if you ritualize the
transition from work to home and if you
train yourself to convert ruminations
into productive forms of thinking you
will succeed banishing ruminations truly
enhanced my personal life but what it
enhanced even more was the joy and
satisfaction I get from my work ground
zero for creating a healthy work-life
balance is not in the real world it's in
our head it's with ruminating if you
want to reduce your stress and improve
your quality of life you don't
necessarily have to change your hours or
your job you just have to change how you
think thank you
[Applause]